What is your paper about?
To find an answer to this question, you first
have to consider the following question as
well.
First and foremost, is what you want to write
about, worth it?
In other words, you have to ask yourself the
“so what” test.
What will be the contribution of the paper
to this field you're interested in?
If you write this paper, what will change
in the way academics see the field?
What will you bring to the table that hasn't
been said before in those terms?
To answer this question you have to build
your literature review, the core elements
in an academic paper.
It will be tantamount to know what your contribution
may be to your field of interest.
The second question is, with whom should I
discuss in order to make sure that you pass
the “so what” test?
How do you ensure that you pass the “so
what” test?
This part is as scientific as it is political.
You have to be sure that the vocabulary that
you use in the frame of your proposition will
be coherent with the way the reviewer will
make sense of the issue you're raising.
To ensure that, identify colleagues and member
of your network that can help you position
the paper in the terms that you have chosen.
Finally, the third question you have to ask
yourself is, what kind of paper do you want
to write?
Academics paper can have different goals.
Whether your goal is theoretical, empirical,
or a methodological one, the design of the
paper will be different.
As the contributions and aim of these papers
are different, so will be the setting, the
methodologies, and the research question.
Your contribution will be impacted by this
orientation.
For instance, if you're looking to publish
in medical journal, for example like the New
England Journal of Medicine, which is oriented
toward clinician as well as researchers.
The journal will not be looking for the same
contribution as a pure biological oriented
journal, for example Nature or Cell.
All these questions and elements are linked
to your research question.
The research question is the main question
raised in your paper, and the one you bring
elements of answer to in the paper.
In short, you have to understand the field
you’re researching in.
Know what you can contribute to it, and know
how to communicate your contribution to this
academic community.
You have to position your paper so that the
community of researchers you are specialized
in the theme you have chosen will accept it.
Many researchers struggle when it comes to
writing literature review for their research
paper.
A literature review is a comprehensive overview
of all the knowledge available on a specific
topic till date.
When you decide on a research topic, usually
the first step you take in the direction of
conducting research is learn more about the
previous research published on the topic,
and this eventually translates into literature
review when you write your research paper.
Literature review is one of the pillars on
which your research idea stands since it provides
context, relevance, and background to the
research problem you are exploring.
Literature review essentially involves two
steps:
Surveying and critically reading the existing
literature: this step is commonly referred
to as experimental literature review.
Summarizing and actually penning down the
gist of your review in an organized manner:
this is known as theoretical review.
Literature review could be a part of a dissertation
or research article and a stand-alone literature
review.
Let us look at this in more detail.
Every research report, thesis, or research
article begins with an introduction to the
topic of research.
This forms the literature review for the article.
The main purpose of the review is to introduce
the readers to the need for conducting the
said research.
A literature review should begin with a thorough
literature search using the main keywords
in relevant online databases such as Google
Scholar, PubMed, etc.
Once all the relevant literature has been
gathered, it should be organized as follows:
Background literature about the broad research
topic to introduce the readers to the field
of study.
Recent progress on the study topic which can
be organized thematically or chronologically.
Ideally, separate themes should be discussed
in a chronological manner to describe how
research in the field has evolved over time
and to highlight the progress in the field.
The review should include a comparison and
contrast of different studies.
Discussing the controversial aspects helps
to identify the main gaps that need to be
worked upon.
This is essential for defining the problem
statement of the study and highlighting the
significance of the research under question.
Once a problem statement has been defined,
the strengths and pitfalls of other studies
that have tackled the problem statement should
be discussed.
This is important for outlining the need and
novelty of the research.
A literature review should not be a mere recounting
of all the available information.
It should be a critical and analytical summary
of the selected literature that guides the
readers through the central theme of the research.
Literature reviews can also be written as
stand-alone articles.
These are not different from the literature
review sections described above; however,
they are not followed by experimental data.
They basically fall into 2 broad categories:
narrative reviews and systematic reviews.
Narrative reviews are theoretical discussions
of relevant information on a particular topic
and its critical analysis.
These are mostly qualitative in nature similar
to the review sections of larger articles.
Narrative reviews are usually organized as
follows:
Introduction that establishes the context
of the field of research and the topic of
the review.
Body is normally used for describing the different
themes under the main topic by dividing them
into different subheadings.
This section compares and contrasts published
studies and identifies gaps that have not
been addressed or have been unsuccessfully
addressed.
Conclusions.
This section differs slightly between reviews
which are part of research articles and narrative
reviews.
The section describes the main conclusions
from analysis of all the current studies and
puts forth further avenues for research.
This section requires critical interpretation
by the author such that the review adds value
to existing literature.
It should bring out ideas and hypotheses that
can explain any discrepancies and provide
solutions to existing problems.
Systematic reviews, on the other hand, follow
a well-planned methodology to qualitatively
or quantitatively analyze a defined number
of studies.
They usually focus on a single question and
have clear study objectives that are worked
upon in a systematic manner.
These studies are based on a well-defined
strategy unlike narrative reviews.
Systematic reviews and narrative reviews are
organized slightly differently.
The details are described below:
Introduction : Systematic reviews begin with
specific research questions that are defined
in terms of the samples and research outcomes
to be studied .
Methods : These studies have a comprehensive
methodology that starts by narrowing down
the literature for the review.
Usually, specific inclusion and exclusion
criteria are set based on the research questions
and databases are searched based on these
criteria.
Once the sample studies have been shortlisted,
they are analyzed in detail .
Results : The results section for these studies
involves comprehensive data analysis to determine
the significance of the study outcomes.
Systematic reviews can be accompanied with
Meta-analysis which involves statistical analysis
of the included studies to increase the power
of the results.
and, Discussion : This section usually interprets
the study data based on their weighted significance
and the power of the results.
The study therefore provides strengthened
results that are validated by the scientific
rigor of the analytical method.
Before starting to write a review, it is important
to determine what kind of review you want
to write and follow the appropriate style
and guidelines.
An effective literature review is important
for the complete life cycle of a research
from defining the right research goals to
correctly interpreting and presenting the
research results.
Let's assume that during the process of literature
review, you have to clearly identify the gap,
but how to concretely fill it.
You have mapped your scientific literature
after laborious work of detection, reading,
writing.
You have depicted out the problem you want
to resolve or at least make a contribution
to the literature that has already been studied
by the researcher in your community.
Then you think it will be interesting to further
the research around this question which needs
more investigation.
And this is what we call the gap.
It's not a matter of has it already been done.
But is it possible to go further in this direction
in an original way?
For example, you should maybe never write
that it has never been done before.
Because the reviewer will tell you that maybe
there was a reason or it's just not interesting.
So now you are aware of this, you must explain
in your article how you can really contribute
to the scientific community by filling the
gap in the literature.
We define it as a blank theoretical space
that you really hope at least partially to
fill thanks to your paper.
The logical way to accomplish this after presenting
your gap is to explain your objectives and
how you want to fill this gap.
The first step will be to present your research
question.
The research question of your article will
be the most important sentence of your article
because it will make the links between the
gaps you will define and how you propose to
fill it.
The research question is the keystone of your
paper.
It has to be clear, precise and concise but
not too general.
If someone asks what is your article about
and sum it up in a few words, the white line
research question should be the answer.
It should be the one sentence tracking out
your paper.